ما كانت لندن تخرج من ازمه الازدحام
والاعطال الفنيه التي لحقت بوسائل نقلها
بسبب الثلوج حتى بدات مرحله فوضى جديده
تتسبب بها هذه المره اضرابات السكك
الحديديه التي يصل عددها الى ثمانيه
اضرابات في ديسمبر ويناير فقط ناهيكا عن
الاضرابات الاخرى التي تشهدها قطاعات
مختلفه
رفضعه 64% من اعضاء هيئه السكك الحديديه
عرض الحكومه القاضي بزياده رواتبهم بنسبته
5% هذا العام وعرضا اخر برفعها من جديد
بنسبه 4% خلال العام المقبل وياتي اضراب
وقطاع الممرضين ليزيد من ازمه الاضطرابات
في البلاد مع اضراب الممرضين يومين خلال
ديسمبر مطالبين برفع اجورهم بنسبه تفوق
ونسبه التضخم وهي تكاليف تقول الحكومه
انها لا يمكن تحملها
ماشي
معارض على هذه الحكومه بدلا من اظهار
قيادته سوناكي يلعب بصحه الناس وهناك
تكلفه بشريه
[موسيقى]
فعليه ان يقول ذلك اذا كان يعتقد ان
الاضرابات صائبه وان هناك قدره على تلبيه
المطالب فعليه ان يقول ذلك
الاخرون اضرابا جديدا سيؤدي الى تاخيرات
في التوصيلات المنزليه ما يعني ان الشهر
هذا قد يكون الاقصى على بريطانيا منذ اكثر
من 20 سنوات
بريطانيا وحكومتها ربما تكون تحت الاختبار
الاصعب فالمقيمون هنا سائم كثره الاضرابات
التي تعطل امورهم اليوميه في مواسم
الاعياد اكثر المواسم ازدحاما ومن المفترض
انها اكثر المواسم فرحا لكن الفرحه تحولت
لكابوس للبعض الذين اتعبتهم كثره
الاضرابات من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي